[Music]
this is camp lemonia in Djibouti one of
the hundreds of military bases the U.S
has overseas about six miles away is
China's first and only military Outpost
the two superpowers say they're in the
east African country of Djibouti to
protect their security and economic
interests and their presence goes far
beyond here the U.S has a long
established network of bases meanwhile
China has started expanding its global
Military Presence at commercial ports
which military experts say can pose a
challenge to the U.S
so we take a look at what's on these
bases and compare their strategies as
China redefines what it means to have a
global Military footprint
a new Obama base is handed over to add
to many others some of America's first
foreign military bases sprung up during
World War II military base is basically
a place where military
forces and weaponry are organized and
gathered David Vine wrote a book about
these U.S facilities and has been
studying them for more than 20 years
foreign bases helped militaries deploy
their forces or have the ability to
deploy their forces into foreign lands
the Japanese launched a surprise attack
after the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor the work had prepared one more
base the U.S started a construction
spree of military bases across the
Pacific and Europe and when the war was
over many American troops remained
abroad the U.S government has used its
military including military bases to
drive its interactions with other
governments and countries the U.S has
treaties with several allies and groups
of countries such as NATO that obliged
to ensure Security in those regions
but there's been criticism from some
locals and those who see bases as
foreign occupation and Facilities to
wage Wars
our Armed Forces stand side by side the
defense department said in a statement
that it respects its host nation
partners and works closely and
transparently with communities despite
the controversy the U.S has kept a
network that allows American troops to
mobilize quickly
for instance following the September
11th attacks the U.S took over Camp
lemonier from France and it became a key
facility for American troops to fight
against al-shabab al qaeda's affiliate
in Somalia in 2018 the Pentagon said the
U.S had more than 500 bases around the
world though some military researchers
and experts say there could be more
China on the other hand doesn't have a
constellation of military bases because
for a long time the leadership viewed it
as a sign of imperialism there had been
Decades of official declaratory policy
from China that they would never station
forces overseas Isaac Cardin is an
assistant professor at the U.S naval war
college and he's been studying China's
Maritime Affairs for more than 10 years
they were attempting to position
themselves as partners of the developing
World specifically against the Americans
who were building bases the beijing's
policies began to shift in the early
2010s as China's economic footprint
began to grow in the first decade of
this Century the country's share in
global trade has almost tripled the
leadership in Beijing recognized that
the scope and intensity of China's
interests overseas required some more
military capability one of those places
was in the Gulf of Aden where the
whether piracy posed threats to global
Shipping this is a route that China
relies on to ship goods between the
mainland and the Mediterranean
so in 2016 in an effort to counter
piracy Beijing said it would set up in
Djibouti what it called an army support
base Djibouti is probably the most
effective place for the people's
Liberation Army to start standing itself
up outside of China's immediate region
given the mission to facilitate sea
operations the Chinese base is equipped
differently from Camp lemonier its first
and foremost a naval base so China built
a Pier from scratch military experts say
it's large enough to host various
vessels in its Fleet including aircraft
carriers destroyers and submarines
the site is about 90 acres and Military
experts estimate it can host about 2 000
Personnel just compare that with Camp
lemonier the American Site is
approximately five times larger and can
house about double the personnel it not
only has Naval support but also land and
air forces that can participate in
military exercises and conflicts and the
bigger size also means the U.S spends
more on paying for the location than
China it pays the djiboutian government
about 63 million dollars annually to
rent the place according to an
independent security Think Tank while
China hasn't disclosed Financial details
a report by the U.S congressional
research service says it costs about 20
million dollars per year to lease the
site
besides Camp lemonier the U.S has even
bigger overseas bases that can house
more than 30 thousand people and they're
usually called Little America it has at
least four schools a hospital
fast food facilities a giant mall and
all the trappings of a significant U.S
town or city
China's single base falls short in terms
of the size and scope of what the U.S
has but Beijing also uses a system of
more than 90 commercial ports and
terminals outside of China
It's Not Unusual for countries including
the US to use them to dock Naval vessels
for repairs and to resupply what is
unusual is that China is able to use
commercial facilities that are owned and
operated
mostly by state-owned Enterprises so the
pla has been granted some type of
preferential access to it Cardin says
most of the ports are partially
controlled by Chinese firms meaning they
own or operate one or more terminals but
all this can still provide a unique
Advantage China is amassing incredible
stockpiles of data about global trade on
the basis of its position in commercial
ports worldwide
Cardin says this Insight alongside a
military presence can be a powerful
combination that could challenge the US
and its allies when you consider that
China is potentially in a position to
deny or delay or disrupt or even control
vital shipments so ultimately this
network puts them in a position where
they have some coercive Leverage
for now military experts say China isn't
pursuing an extensive network like the
US the concerns have been growing among
some American officials that Beijing
could be planning new bases they are
seeking actively seeking a military base
on the Atlantic coast of Africa the
place where they've actually made
progress toward this is Equatorial
Guinea
China's defense ministry didn't respond
to a request for comment on its base
plans in Africa or whether Beijing could
use commercial ports to counter other
countries
the U.S defense department said it's
concerned about the lack of transparency
and Clarity around beijing's
negotiations with host Nations
so as the U.S and China compete for
Global influence the networks that they
build and maintain could become one of
their most essential military assets
[Music]